voil est il est 16h 160 caravanes ont
investi la plaine de la gloriette après
de longues heures d'attente et des
bouchons qui ont paralysé une partie de
la ville ça a été très long madame très
long franchement très long mque à côté
de moi là qui a 74 ans est diabétique
voyez-vous donc pas des viille personne
comme ça âgé il faut être compréhensible
vous savez depuis ce matin il nous faut
attendre et puis finalement on rentre
quand même depuis 10h on est là quand
même ça fait long la tente ben ça fait
long avec les enfantsrière 4 an hein
maintenant faut que j'avance vous avez
une place ça y est ça y est c'est bon
c'est sûr pour la mairie c'est une
arrivée surprise les évangéliste n'était
attendu que dimanche moi je ne sais pas
ce qui s'est passé dans les autres
communes précédemment dans la journée ou
dans la veille ou à la veille ou à
l'avant-veille notamment en bois je
crois au chargé mais je ne sais plus
très bien ou j'ai cru comprendre que ils
ne devait pas être les bienvenus et donc
ils sont échoués on va dire sur la ville
de tour donc il a bien faillli faire
quelque chosees et prendre nos
responsabilités impossible d'accueillir
160 caravanes et un chapiteau sur l'air
de grand passage les gens du voyage qui
ne voulaient pas se séparer en plusieurs
groupes ont ainsi décidé d'investir la
plaine de la gloriette on nous a empêché
de rentrer hein il y a quelques
caravanes ils étaient rentrés sur le
terrain et après la la la police ont
bloqué le passage pendant un temps c un
petit peu tendu évidemment entre les
forces de police qui faisaient leur
travail toujours façon sereine mais
évidemment que cétait tendu puisqu'on
était quasiment de 9h30 10h du matin
jusqu'à 14 15h une convention devrait
être signée entre la ville et la
communauté qui repartira mardi prochain